après la confrontation entre bernard
laroche le principal inculpé de
l'assassinât du petit grégory bernard
laroche qui était confrontée à sa belle
soeur et à d'autres témoins après cette
confrontation qui a duré plus de cinq
heures et demie ses avocats ont demandé
sa mise en liberté pour le dossier est
très largement insuffisant et la réunion
des principaux témoins dans le bureau du
juge d'instruction aurait permis de
confirmer l'alibi de bernard laroche
une enquête qui risque donc de retourner
à la case départ su place sur place
isabelle bechler après la longue
confrontation de 6 heures hier dans le
bureau du juge bernard laroche en
sortant du palais de justice même s'il
proteste de son innocence ne peut pas
ignorer que la rumeur publique le tient
pour coupable une rumeur publique
nourrie par la presse elle même nourri
par les milieux proches de l'anc est
aussi la surprise sera t-elle d'autant
plus grande quand les avocats de la
défense annonçant qu'il dépose une
demande de mise en liberté pour bernard
laroche
aucun rapport de toxines ne figure dans
le dossier d'instruction et les
documents ou graphologique n'y figurent
pas non plus à la demande de la défense
l'emploi du temps de bernard laroche a
été minutieusement vérifiée par
l'audition de très nombreux témoins mais
les témoignages cités par la défense
sont bien fragiles
muriel la jeune belle soeur de la roche
à bôle innocente et elle sait déjà qu'on
trop dit trois fois quand l alibi
crucial de leur du rapt de grégory de
17h à 17h30 le 16 octobre
il n'est fournie que par louise jacob et
sa fille chantal toutes deux handicapées
mentales même si le dossier de
l'instruction peut sembler incomplet à
la défense les avocats n'obtiendront pas
si facilement la liberté pour leur
client le juge lambert a gardé dans sa
manche les témoins à charge et la
confrontation n'a pas dû l'ébranler dans
son intime conviction
seul marie-ange laroche persuadé de
l'innocence de son mari a repris
confiance
oui